PEGI 16 Saiga
you are my son but I've done all I can
to protect you
the gods smile on you Octavian you're a
good soldier I'm a politician we don't
need more politicians it's not more
speeches in the Senate that will change
the world
Rome is dying
why do you think Caesar favored you so I
was loyal
no Octavian he saw in you the potential
to continue his legacy not to follow him
to exceed him
Antony cannot be trusted his heart lies
in Egypt we must confront the reality
that civil war is inevitable and how
will bloodshed save the people of Rome
you are not meant to save them you are
meant to lead them
men are troubled when their moment has
come I am NOT Caesar I don't have his
strength the people loved him and they
will love you
you can't think like an ordinary man you
must reach beyond mortal ambition and do
what has never been done
survive my son Rome must have an emperor
you
creating out here from Creative Assembly
well its save if you want more
information on the Emperor edition of
which that awesome trailers apart you
can do so by clicking on our faces it
goes straight through to rally point
episode 21 which has the full lowdown on
the Emperor Edition yeah all the updates
that went into ROM two since beginning
and the new updates that come with the
Emperor Edition so check it out